titanfall 2 is coming next month but  don't expect any bonuses for EA access  members I'm Tony and this is your  titanic GameSpot news update  titanfall 2 is not listed on the access  FAQ page and its exclusion from the  service has been confirmed by game  reactor so what does this mean normally  access members can play games 5 days  early and save 10% on digital content  but that won't be the case with  titanfall 2 develop a respawn hasn't  explained why the game is excluded but  has also said it could be available at  some point after launch titanfall 2 is  headed to Xbox one ps4 and PC on October  28th two betas have been held so far so  hopefully you've gotten a chance to try  out the game's multiplayer for yourself  if not you don't have much longer to  wait to keep up with all the news from  EA respawn and titanfall 2 you're  already in the right place